New Hampshire land of covered bridges
maple syrup and white people it's the
ninth state in the Union and the first
to vote in the presidential primaries
why well it's been that way since 1920
and they liked the attention so much
that in 1975 the state legislature voted
to make it law which is why even though
New Hampshire is small it's a big deal
when it comes to deciding next president
the motto around these parts is live
free or die which speaks to New
Hampshire rights independent streak
forty-four percent of registered voters
don't identify as a Republican or
Democrat maybe that's why outsiders
Bernie and Trump are doing so well in
the polls here it also helps that
senator Sanders home state of Vermont is
right next door if a candidate wins here
they get a lot of attention and money
wins here have propelled candidates like
Mitt Romney and John McCain to the
nomination and all but one president in
the last 40 years has either one Iowa or
New Hampshire in the primaries
candidates are spending big money here
in order to woo voters including
millions on advertising
some like this guy our banking
everything on New Hampshire he's made
hundreds of stops here but New Hampshire
doesn't look like the rest of America
it's 91 % white whereas the country of
the whole is only sixty-two percent
white the mission is any like good at
indian food around here or a food let's
go with indian food now okay actually
it's also not as urban as the rest of
america with only sixty percent living
in cities as opposed to eighty-one
percent nation wide so it's strange and
maybe even a red flag that this small
state in the northeast corner of America
has such a disproportionate role when it
comes to elect in the next president I
guess this is what democracy looks like
and we're along for the ride
Oh